thank you for inviting me today I'm
going to talk about how to solve LP
faster this is a Jo with
Aon uh today we will talk about this
problem we want to minimize a linear
function on a poop a greater than b uh
in here I call M is the number of
constraint and N is the number of
we and usually you have a polop the
number of const is wor equals to the
number of variables that is the usual
case in practice however sometimes you
could have some object have much more
coning for example this one or something
like matching poop or something else so
in this research we want to ask how can
we solve those situation
faster and now I will talk about what is
the pevious result on this P basically
almost all prace result is iterative
Method what I mean is the Alam look like
this form uh the Alam will start with
some initial pwn and then if that P is
not optimal then you improve that that
pond until you get to the optimal
Pond and the total running time is uh
the number of iteration times the cost
of per iteration and in this talk I will
only focus on how many iteration we need
to Sol LP and in the next talk he will
talk about how how much it cost for each
iteration and here we call
from if uh each iteration is polom time
and you don't need to use LP software in
each iteration otherwise I have a one
iteration LP Sofer
so yeah so let's see what is the
previous result in fact there is much
more previous result I just select some
uh to show it here the first result is
simplest method
the L fation is exponential but usually
in practice is really good and the the
second result by C is the ellip method
this is the first po time alum for
LP and then this method is by kamaka
that is the first inter P method it
takes uh M iteration and it improve by R
get to square m after that that result
all result the the EXP there is still
one half but but people try to see how
to improve M to n and the first result
by there he improve to
mn4 and then finally let's s get
the result squ n and and in certain
Theory this is the best result you can
do using inal
method uh no there is two thing one is
yeah Square every result is square and
the first result is by R and the second
thing is let's Dr g sare m but this is
not efficient I will tell you later why
is not efficient in my sense and in our
res result we cannot exactly get s m but
we get uh with some
Pol and then to solve me we need to
improve square and to square rank in
next talk everyone will talk what what
do I mean by S rank and both method is
efficient
so we M Mar last year so for for mass
for certain LP such as unrated Mass full
problem in fact you he can decide in
meod that want in M2 F4 3 over s
iteration so it's better than sward but
this is not for General
LP uh yeah and and the the talk outline
is something like this I will explain
the W the reneg AL because that is a
easiest uh alum in the in method and
then I will show why scroll n is
possible and then I will
show uh in fact our result is inspired
by the Y Al so I will explain the Y Al
and we saw how to improve the Y Al to
scroll n
yeah so in this talk I will not try to
use the standard way to teach about in I
will use my way of thinking so is not
standard uh but hope you like
that uh you can think instead of in this
to I will think about solving LP is like
maintaining a center of a
poop for example say somehow you this is
the polop and you want to find that pwn
and say say each iteration you first in
the first iteration you somehow get a
center I I didn't Define Center here now
I will Define it later imagine for
example a CG or whatever Center you like
and then each iteration you first put
the constraint there when you put the
constraint there you change the poop so
you need to update the center and in
each iteration you want to move the con
constraint closer to the automo Pond and
each step you need to maintain the
center say if each uh iteration you can
move the constraint by F portion then
after one over F iteration you solve the
lp so the whole problem is how can we
Define a center such that we can move
the conent as much as
possible um but why we Le the center or
what is Center for example if you don't
do anything like this each time you just
keep pushing the constraint and then
until you hit the
you hit the current pwn then you may not
know what to do then maybe you do some
silly stuff and then it look like a
simplest method it could work in
practice but it's quite difficult to
prove anything so you can think the
center is try to use some goal
information to avoid bad
decision
so uh
because just not to confin confuse
people I try to say the Alum again say
we say here I assume the optimal value
is zero for Simplicity then say we start
with uh value T is very very large and
we find a center for that polop our our
goal is to find x c transer xal to Z and
a x greater than b so we start with a
point we can find a center then each
iteration when T is larger than zero
then we decrease the t a little bit
and then update the center for for the
LI this is the W outline for the AL a
general framework for the AL and this is
usually called Inon meth because each
iteration you maintain interon of your
poto and some people may ask because
finding a initial point is equiv to
solve LP but in fact there is General
trick to deal with that uh situation for
for example you can for example if a x
greater than b you cannot find a point
then you can consider a x greater than b
1 million then is easier in fact you can
choose some constant there you can
always find a initial point so that is
notot a
problem yeah so so then how should we
defy a center uh the usual way to Def a
center in in method is why function say
we we are given the function on the po
top that is a convers and smooth
function and we assume the function will
P up on the boundary we call those
function is barrier
function for example uh the standard
function they use is called standard L
barrier function is summation of log s s
for example we want toate the standard L
Bar function at that point then the is s
is the distance to your each constraint
we call those a slack and then the
standard LW bar function is you just sum
up the LW of the
slack and we Define the center is the
minimum of the bar
function yeah so so we now have a center
then what the group center allow us to
push the con as much as possible uh it
turns
out uh uh the key property is about one
thing for any from one I will always
assume the center is induced by B
function
p and and this is the center this is the
minum point of the function p and
because that is the conx function so
locally the cont to L is look like
ellipso if you enal your ellipsoid until
it touch the point you get the first
ellip and when you an continue to an
your ellip you will cover the whole poop
you get the second ellipsoid and we call
that ellipsoid is a Lambda one thing if
the ratio of two two is
Lambda
and is a standard F about
self I will not give you the formal
definition but I will only give you the
geometric
meaning uh we call per p is Lambda self
cooton if p is move why Rel the B
function to be smooth imagine if the
function is slow smooth when you push
the constraint then the function keep
changing the path then we don't know how
to maintain our center that is bad the
other property that I will emphasize in
this T is p give Lambda
one for example this is a bad one bad B
if the local ellipsoid look like that
thing you said you have an ellipsoid
corresponding to PX you're just taking
Hassan yeah yeah okay yeah
okay yeah so so the standard Fe is uh so
is that equivalent to the standard
definition in terms of third derives and
stuff defition uh this is a less
conditioning notot notot as sufficient
for interior point or not is this
condition alone sufficient for no l only
uh no h let yeah the standard self C
bence only implies this but this uh
doesn't really imply that one but this
is the geometric meaning I want to
convey yeah so you can refin the my
Center Alum look like this each time the
barrier only not only give you a center
also give you a ellip that approximate
your point so you can find the the
framework I propose is look like this
each time you move the constraint and
the bar new B and keep give you a good
Waring of your PO so you can think the
alist try to approximately know what the
point you are trying to uh
optimize and but why oh I I miss the
slid there and and then give self foring
then the Fe will give you Al to solve uh
in two point in square Lambda iteration
but why is square
Lambda however in this talk I will try
to avoid any proof I avoid anying proof
so I can only give you a LDA proof yeah
anyway so you just uh if you don't like
a
general uh B referencing then you can
always thing about p is the standard
Ling uh for this slide you ly to believe
me uh for little me for assuming those
certain smoothness assumption then then
if you given any pwn that is AAL but
within
constant ER to the automo pwn say py is
less than the M plus 0.5 then Newton
method will give you a way to find the M
pwn in in constant step because of
certain smoothness something I didn't
tell
you and
and and so you
can and
then now I call the Y is the O Center
and this is the O Center this is the
constraint Orin constraint and you want
to push
it
and again by the smooth assumption I
didn't tell you when you push the
constraint a little bit then
the the first equation p y
P minimum P this is the era when you are
using the O Center and we want to put
remember in the last slid I promised you
whenever the aror is less than a
constant then you can find the center so
each step what you can do is you can
push push the constraint such that the O
Center still give you a constant eror
for the L Center if this holds then you
can use little method to find the little
Center so in fact you just do some
algebra you can show in fact that is
bounded
by uh this is say this is the little
constraint that is the old constraint
and if
you push it to here then
you I call the Rasel is this is a little
Gap and that is the O Gap when the
little Gap over the O Gap is constant
then
you the old Center approximate the
little Center very well so you so you
can find the little Center by little
method but but then now the problem is
that do we know the Gap is small I mean
imagine if your little Center is here
and you want to push that way then the
thing you can move is very very tightly
so now comes with the one thing
assumption because we know the B give
you a Lambda rounding uh for example you
have a ellip here I just call it radius
one and then we know from the Bing that
give you a Lambda r that mean that when
you an by Lambda this cover the whole
ellip so for example if you want to push
that direction and say this is the
optimal
value uh then then we know the distance
to the B is at least one because there
is a radius one inside and we look the
distance here is as at most Lambda
because you have a Lambda you the whole
thing and so each step you can move
constant compared to the whole distance
and this give you the proof Y is Lambda
iteration any question
here I'm a little confused why the why
the El that contains the PO also matters
is there intution
that uh imagine say this look like hyper
and each
iteration the the problem is the the
user little method you only allow to
move inside certain if each iteration
you only allow to
move the distant like that one then you
l s and step to
there yeah
I'm
sorry you say here when you move the
worst case is we can only move constant
but here that is very far away is Lambda
far away that might be yeah that that
may be a trouble that may the optimal
point it may be way over there or
something yeah yeah yeah so you live to
push a lot of time inter that the
properties of Newton's method is that if
you're sure that it's not going to jump
out of the entire um polytop in the
first place then you know it's going to
basically stay in the ellipsoid that's
yeah yeah yeah okay and therefore if
that
electroid is too small it's going to
take you a long time to move where's the
square root coming from yeah the elix
siiz yeah yeah basically I not able to
show you because uh I don't have a good
picture to draw but basically the
previous proof we measure the progress
by the this time from here to here but
turns out the correct measurement is the
here to here and then you just do some
algebra H in fact you can prove this Gap
is O approximator will uh I don't know
how to say anyway yeah
uh approximates the real what uh
approximate the real deity Gap
in fact if you use the standard lber
fing then this Gap is uh the wheel Gap
over
M yeah so that is a l frame to do sorry
was
kid
yeah yeah so roughly speaking you can
find whenever the bar fing is smoth and
give you Lambda rounding then you get a
s Lambda iterations let me check this in
my memory of vinegar
I thought the way he got the going from
Lambda to root Lambda was by treating
the constraint plane that he was adding
as if he had a root l a multiple of it
yeah yeah yeah so that it factored into
the barrier function more times but is
that compatible with this uh you yeah
both in both cases you can also proof
that you
can yeah just uh if you would would end
m of that then the poof look lier okay
but but you can still P for this
version yeah I the in was saying was
more along the lines of uh that you have
to use a primal dual potential function
and the square root is coming from doing
something Primal
dual drawing Primal is pictures and that
you know the square root is coming from
yeah being able to update your DS
too yeah uh uh in my way of thinking the
reason of square Lambda is uh in fact to
really get square Lambda you need to
push more than that pwn but however you
you can imagine when you push that you
push the con there you can expect the
pawn will go that way so even you
push beyond that pawn in fact you are
still not touching the center so you can
p in fact you can push that much but
yeah but that require more more
calculus yeah so let us see why the
standard loening is bad remember the
standard lering is the sum of lot of the
slack uh you can
imagine uh the center is like you put a
metet on each constraint of the potop
and then your P just come Repose away
from each metet then the reason the
analytic Bing is bad because you can
repeat certain constraint by m times
then you like putting M Manet there then
your oppon will push
away then here you will get push away by
here like one over M there so the one
thing here is very really bad because
the you saw locally here look like this
one you lead to an M times to cover the
whole
Po and but you that the ti reason why
this is bad uh because we know in
practice usually it take less than 60
steps and in
fact missu and you so that if you start
with a random poop usually the first
step you can progress a lot so if in
fact many people try to come up with
that that b referencing is bad a lot
until this year M andak so
in fact you Le sare M step they con
count example m is in fact exponential
to n and the in method Le to T
exponentially many step to Res every
test of the
hyper so so in fact uh uh the square m
is tight for that bar
function so and and now I will talk
about then why we believe it could be
square
n yeah in fact uh liosi and last dve so
that this B give you all and self for
coton that mean using this Bing to Sol
LP you get a scoll and
iteration and and just to give a ination
for that bar fencing the B fencing is
look like say each time you have uh what
what is that I mean there's a little o
up there yeah uh I was planning to
draw so you have the com set look like
this and then say your current point x
is here then you consider the polar on
at of the con set I want this point
which I cannot really Draw Something
look like this whenever your pwn is
closer to the boundary then the polar
will become larger so this B ref fing
will B up when you close to
B and and the reason why this B fing is
good because the hent of this Bing
roughly equivalent to the second moment
of this Matrix the polar of your con
set and we know from Canon noas and
Simon uh for any con set if you look at
the second moment Matrix uh the second
moment Matrix will give you a o1 thing
so you can imagine the second moment
Matrix give the o1 thing of the Polar
set and you can take the polar and then
you will get better the o1 of your
origin set and this is the reason why
they get o self
cordance however this B fencing is a
little bit difficult to compare let's
see why uh at least for now the the only
way I know how to compare second moment
Matrix is to compare po many time
sampling on the Polar polytop the polar
com set I mention we need to compete
second moment for that one so you need
to sample Point sample Point randomly in
Des
set again yeah yeah I just don't want to
prise and then to get one sampling you
need to do M chain day is still problem
so this is still good for for our
definition of efficiency but the major
problem is to compete one step of mar
chain you need to implement the
separation Oracle for this set and the
only way I know how to implement the
separation Oracle is to solve a LP on
that con set so you are requiring to
solve the the similar LP you didn't
reduce the dimension or what so so this
SP reference basically asks you to solve
poom many similar LP and that's why we
call it lot
efficient so the major open problem is
how can we get a o efficient
self and in this results we get all
end yeah and our result is inspired by
the volumetric Bing by the W
result the volumetric fing is look like
this uh the PS is the standard Lo B fun
then you can imagine now you start with
the standard while standard
loing then you take the hian that mean
you look at the yipo around that pwn and
then you compute the volume of that yipo
and then you take Loot and and why did I
say you you mix up with the orig bar and
he say this is a good bar by the way
this is volumetric because you're
Computing a volume of some ellip
oil uh to see why this is good we need
to look at some example the same example
before this is the previous case the
L if you put m m there it will push here
the distance is 1 M but you can imagine
the volumetric bar look like this
instead of permanent maget they put some
electric magnet here I will explain in
the next side why is a electric maget uh
but you can just try to compute for this
B function the distance here is 1 over M
to
13 yeah I will explain next SL why is
electric and and in fact why they are
able to prove this barri is MN Square MN
bar function so you take the so the so
if you use this to solve LP you get MN
to4 and and to see why the volumetric
pering is good really to do some
calculus uh say I say I want any point
in your con set or poop then you what is
PS X it's the standard
variant yeah yeah PS is the standard and
we try to at one end at any interior
point you try to approximate your
volumetric baring by a certain weighted
L Bar
fing uh in fact any baring you can write
in this form because you you just take
the tail expansion and you choose the
weight s you choose the weight of the
weighted L function such that first
thetive match the original one you can
always Cho choose way such that it
happens and turn so you can find the
volumetric bar is like choosing a weight
of this form Sigma plus n/
M and and sigma is leage scores uh I
will explain here you can imagine left
score is a way to measure how important
is a certain W just to illustrate for
example for this Matrix B if you put it
into this
formula and you will get this coning is
very important the importancy is one
because this is only repesent it doesn't
repr presentent by other constraint and
those two constraint is less important
but this is more important than that
because the number here is
larger for example like
this and there is uh in general uh we
know the left score segma is always
between one and zero and some of left
score is the number of variables and
whenever you repeat certain constraint
one times then the leverage score of
that constraint will decrease by
two yeah so you can imagine this is a
way to measure how important is a
coning and now having think so you can
find the volumetric barri is trying to
look at your coning Matrix and then see
how important is each wall and then we
we the Bing by that
import that's why I put the electric
Manet there you can change the
Mana and and to look back on the
original
Bing to look back the previous examples
imagine you have a c one interal and the
C con will K times then if you at the if
you say your current point is in the
center then if you put in that formula
that mean you need to compare what is
the SL inverse
a when you at the center point every SL
is one so the SL inverse a is L one
Matrix so what is the s y inverse Matrix
S is the slack measure at the point Y
and the Matrix diag diag
Matrix yeah when you at the center point
then every con is equally
important then the bar function will
push you to there but when you are
closer to to this constraint then
certainly because the SL here is smaller
then SL inverse is larger so the
leverage score of this W will become
larger so so when you go close enough to
this point then the the melet was sh
enough to push to balance at that point
that's why this barrier is slightly
better than the standard l
b now we can look at our
B yeah basically uh the first sentence
is the previous uh volumetric bing this
is like you start with if you think
about it a little bit more you can think
the wider result is showing given the
standard L Bing
you can take lot determine h of Def
function and get a better bar function
so there is no reason you should stop
this process so how about if you define
a process to create the B function by
one by one step and then see how good is
that however this formula is pretty
difficult to analyze so we do the
analysis like the previous slides say
imagine your PK your your last your
previous pering look like a weighted
Ling and then do the calculation again
then you will notice at one any point Y
then the little will look like this form
you look like to reate your constraint
by Sigma plus n/
M
notice uh the constraint Matrix is not s
inverse a is square w s inverse a that's
why it depends on the p b
function and then and then Sly then what
is the Lal object is Al so so you can
think each step we update the weight by
this equation and we want to understand
the what is the limit of this per
reference as so we define object P
Infinity is just uh whatever weight
satisfy this equation we just ignore
that ter question the way of the
recursive formula I would expect that
give this n / m in front of PS of X
doesn't that compound as you go oh yeah
so you yeah yeah you need to re wait no
but it looks like it oh is that going
into
the keep having the log of Si * n/ m as
opposed to yeah at the end you after
case step you should divide everything
by K then you get some of weight is n
okay
yeah yeah that's why the file equation I
I omit that ter okay oh oh this is oh
this is a typo this is the P weate okay
yeah yeah so so what is that object uh
so now you can imagine so now we start
to understand what is that object the W
is the The Leverage score of the Matrix
we by W if you guys have seen the top by
which pan you remember this
object
and should there be an n m in the top
line or not this is weight this is typo
this is weight but the first place there
should it say that or not yes oh this oh
there is many type of there are all of
those this is the weight days is low n/
M and me he uh
P1 is just to make sure the all one's
Vector is
normalized yeah yeah there is L there
should I WR in that
Bo too
late yeah so we go to next slide
Happ yeah we remember we want to
understand that object we equals to left
SC to understand that object we we
ignore the SL for a moment we try to
divide the term there if the we is not
zero we can divide we divide it as the
to we try to understand what is
to uh L assume that is low SL
then say take a look of this poop a less
than one and then look at the ellip look
like this
form in fact the say of uh say yeah the
distance from there to there is one
because that is less than one is it h
yeah and then turn so you can compute
how is measuring that
distance so what is that equation
telling you uh when when f is less than
one that mean the ellip is inside this
polytop
and turn so you can think this condition
is trying to make the as large as
possible such that either W is zero or
it touch the p and in fact this is the
automatic condition for
John
so so you can find the the the the
limiting weight is representing the
joint for this
P this the p
any
question yeah
so now look at
the yeah remember our Bing the recursive
definition is each time you replace the
B by lot that has of the ref so you can
imagine the fal object also satisfy that
equation and then you just put in the
formula for the baring we remember our
Bing will look like a l bar weighted L
Bing so the H will look like that form
and remember that is the joint side so
the whole formula is just Computing The
Joint side of s inverse a x that poop
and turn so you can draw the object like
here this Bing is look like you start
with a potop at certain point x you
symmetrize your poop at that point and
then you compu the
joint of that intersection and then
compu the volume and this is
the the Bing you get when you repeat the
r
process but this very is not not perfect
uh in particularly this is not smooth uh
for example you
imagine you so the b f is look like each
time you compare joint but joint is not
smoo object for example this example if
you try to push the constraint down uh
originally the IDE doesn't touch this
constraint but when you push it down
enough you suddenly touch this
constraint and then it will change the
direction because it LO some little
information so this is notot a good B
function and and Lally you can think the
oh Lally you can write down the
Jo B in this formula and this formula
have a problem because of this
constraint W greater than
zero or you can think because this is
not a shly concave function so the
optimizer is not smooth
yeah
so yeah so let recap what we I'm saying
uh when use the S L it give you scroll M
iteration and then the the why they
propos the volumetric Bion it look like
you do some process on the original B
function then you get this this give you
MN
to4 and then we we just suggest we
should repeat that process until you get
conver to some answer then you get the
joing uh but this pering is not Smo so
how should we do it anyone know what
should we do when the fencing is not
Smo you add the volumetric barrier to
it uh the answer is to equalize yes yeah
uh basically in our paper we regularize
in that way uh we raise the power W to
certain
power uh in any way to see you can you
raise the power on this
term then or your concern is a simp
become is less simp so this is
smoother uh anyway uh because some
people don't like race the power of that
thing so in fact you can also do that
but we didn't do it in our paper you can
just put the entropy term there because
this is joh concave so everything is
good uh but we still explain this
because it relate to the the richan
talk I will explain
later yeah oh yeah I explain here uh
yeah and in fact when we write the paper
we don't know why we waste the power we
just lotice when you ra the power you
get some better property and turn is
relate to a soal LP l r uh F than to
Cohan and Pen we uh we know is a very
important
object for example if you are given a
matrix B and you consider a weight
satisfy that equ then which told us you
can resample your con such that it it
can give you a small Matrix approximate
or poop so in some sense you can find
our our in meth try to use those R to
help you soft LP although we cannot use
for sampling because in that case in our
case P will be l m so here if we really
really large we cannot use it to sample
length but we can use it for something
LP you have think our result is like
that also there is geometrical meaning
of the lowest
weight you can think lowest weight is
trying to find the maximum
volume that is almost inside your polop
but the definition of Almost Is it
satisfy certain PM
constraint when p is infinity then as we
discuss is exactly corresponding to the
joint and in
the uh which pan they show how to
compute the lowest W for p less than
four and certainly our prer show how to
compute lowest W for p equals to
infinity and and the way
is there's multiple way to do that uh
the W paper somehow give you the r is
like this uh that is the
previous uh recursive definition of the
rate in fact you can
prove you need toize the rate and then
you can so exactly conver to the L pH W
rate or you can say the W give you the
joint and
recently we together so in fact you can
extend that formula to P greater than
two so now for any P we can find the Lis
weight and
so uh and and this is the reason why our
B function is compartible because we can
compare those
weight yeah so just to do the
conclusion for any po you can consider
this B ref and the end main f is this
give you square and iteration Al to
solve
LP in picture you can find each
iteration you move the cost constraint
and then you remove a regularized
version of trite look like
this and
and notice that in this talk I didn't
tell you exactly how to do F calculation
and the main goal of our research is to
find LP software fast enough to solve M
fast to to make a better Mass Alum
however this approach have two problem
now is first you cannot write mass in
this way with only M rebles because you
Le each you need a varable for each m so
there is
ambles also uh if you look carefully
when you compu the leage score you need
to
computer Matrix look like that and this
is too slow for for gra problem so in
next every we'll talk about how to fix
that two
P yeah thank
you